[Music]
in the grasslands of Mauritania a
gazelle suffering from tuberculosis
takes its last breath collapsing near a
small pool the animals corpse threatens
to infect the water but for the deserts
cleanup crew this body isn't a problem
it's a feast weighing up to 10 kilograms
and possessing a wingspan of nearly
three meters the lappet-faced vulture is
the undisputed king of the carcass this
birds powerful beak and strong neck
easily tear through tough hide and
muscle tissue opening entry points for
weaker vultures to dig in this colossal
competition is too dangerous for the
tiny egyptian badger with a wingspan of
only 180 centimeters this vulture
migrated to africa from his family nest
in Portugal using thermal updrafts to
stay aloft for hours at a time
but upon arrival he finds himself near
the bottom of the pecking order
fortunately what he lacks in size he
makes up for in intelligence a short
distance away he spots an unguarded
ostrich nest full of immense but
impenetrable eggs using a large rock he
smashes one open for a well-earned meal
though he'll circle back to the gazelle
once the larger birds are gone high
above the commotion are repels griffon
vultures soaring at an altitude of over
11,000 metres these birds fly higher
than any other animal at this height
they can't see individual carcasses but
the sight of their fellow vultures
guides them to the feeding their
featherless heads help them regulate the
sudden rise in temperature as they
descend and keep them clean as they tear
into the decaying gazelle the carcasses
stripped clean in hours well before the
rotting meat infects the water supply
and the tuberculosis doesn't stand a
chance at infecting the vultures these
birds have evolved the lowest gastric
pH in the animal kingdom allowing them
to digest diseased carrion and waste
without becoming sick in fact species
like the mountain-dwelling
bearded vulture have stomachs so acidic
they can digest most bones in just 24
hours this adaptation help smaller
vultures supplement their diet with dung
while larger vultures can consume
diseased meat up to three days old their
acidic stomachs protect them from living
animals to their rancid vomit
scares off most predators these stomachs
of Steel are essential to removing
pathogens like cholera anthrax and
rabies from the African ecosystem but
while vultures can easily digest natural
waste man-made chemicals are another
story
diclofenac a common veterinary drug used
to treat cattle in India is fatal to
vultures and because local religious
beliefs prohibit eating beef scavengers
often consume cattle carcasses since the
1990s the drug along with threats from
electricity pylons and habitat loss has
contributed to a 95 percent decline in
the region's vulture population in
nearby Africa poachers intentionally
poison carcasses to prevent the birds
presence from alerting authorities to
their location one poisoned carcass can
kill over 500 vultures today more than
50% of all vulture species are in danger
in regions where vultures have gone
extinct corpses take 3 times longer to
decay these carcasses contaminate
drinking water while feral dogs and rats
carry the diseases into human
communities the asian and african
vulture crisis has led to an epidemic of
rabies in India where infections kill
roughly 20,000 people each year
fortunately some communities have
already realized how important vultures
are conservationists have successfully
banned drugs like diclofenac while other
researchers are working to repopulate
vulture communities through breeding
program
some regions have even opened a vulture
restaurants where farmers safely dispose
of drug free livestock with help
vultures will be able to continue their
role conserving the health of our planet
transforming death and decay into life
as with the dwindling vulture population
taking away just one important species
can undermine an entire ecosystem but
what makes one system resilient and
another vulnerable check out this video
to learn how biodiversity keeps our
planets ecosystems healthy and thriving